cette nuit je sais pas si vous voyez je
suis assez fatigué parce que je n'ai pas
dormi je vous le dis j'ai passé toute la
nuit j'étais dans le stress j'étais pas
bien j'étais au bout de ma vie puisque
cette nuit il y avait la finale de l'us
open c'est un des tournois du grand
chelem c'est comme roland garros voilà
il ya quatre tournois majeurs et l'us
open dont c'est à new york
et c'est vrai que c'est un des très
grands tournois c'est comme on l'en
garros mais sur une autre surface et
c'est rafael nadal qui a gagné mon rafa
qui a gagné en cinq sets
j'ai pleuré 7,52 alors regardé la
victoire de nadal et j'ai un truc à vous
montrer plus de bad boys dans le tennis
et ça devient de plus en plus haut vous
verrez regarder pour l'instant nadal
[Applaudissements]
cet accident
[Musique]
c'est surtout 5
you know when arosa le fond des choses
[Applaudissements]
gagnez votre medvedev
un joueur russe c'est venu très très
abondante qui fait un carton en ce
moment était très drôle ce qu'ils ont
montré les 19 victoires de nadal entendu
en chef et lui a dit voilà vous avez vu
si ça avait été moi qui ai gagné vous
auriez montrer quoi c'est un petit peu
si on fait un truc sur la carrière de
deux ter cette personne c'est prêt est
ce que j'ai kiffé c'est que pendant le
tournoi américain il ya deux choses que
j'ai kiffé 1
on a vu des bad boys et 2 je pense qu'il
ya une 9e je vous dévoile et qui sait de
qui il s'agit qui veut absolument le
pechoux encore une meuf à
l'international vous allez voir ça dans
un instant pour le moment ce que j'ai
kiffé c'est que pendant tout le tournoi
il ya eu des joueurs qui commençait à
jouer les bad boys ça y est pendant le
tennis ça part en cacahuète total
regardez c'était une grosse d'arcachon
vous ai fait un top 3 des bad boys de la
semaine rien
[Applaudissements]
6 passes
eh oui
[Musique]
le mot udev de mont louis wind
pourquoi je me permets j'embrasse
j'embrasse mon frérot benoît paire qui
est actuellement en fait voilà je suis
leur brasse et il s'est énervé parce que
le joueur lui parler et c'est est
validée pourquoi il veut pas du tout
quand vous jouez pas la culture de plus
en plus debout medvedev est très beau et
quand j'étais allé à roland-garros avec
vous avez vu je mets un petit belge qui
était très abîmée david goffin et vous
m'aviez donné son numéro de téléphone et
j'ai perdu
bah ouais et ba et ba et lui c'est lui
qui m'a demandé ce que vous le perdit sa
merci très très bien c'est bon c'est bon